[Music]
i mean we see
already today good and bad fallouts
of the use of artificial intelligence
technology so
consider in the medical domain the
wonderful capacity
of ais to read x-rays
for example to read medical imaging you
know there's wonderful potential but
then consider
data privacy even in the medical domain
um
you know if we don't have the proper
social and legislative guard rails for
the development
of ai technology including by ai just
mean
any kind of predictive algorithms
um then i think it's it's uh not a good
thing
so if we want to move forward and get
the benefits
of ai technology we need to have a sort
of
careful path forward
[Music]
i'm very very excited about
the possibility of ai going inside the
head
for example to help individuals who have
locked in syndrome
or individuals who can't move for other
reasons
but the same technologies that
may actually help individuals who are
radically disabled um may also be the
kind of technologies
um that pose dangers
so i think again things have to move
forward very carefully
um so elon musk recently demoed the use
of a brain chip
in pigs actually and that technology as
he noted
is incredibly transformative for
individuals
who can't move um wow right
and and it's exciting that it may be you
know
ten years away from development actual
use that is
um or even five years away from actual
use
but at the same time suppose that normal
people feel obligated to get
brain chips so that they can um continue
their jobs and keep up with artificial
intelligence
to augment their intelligence there i
think we have to be very careful because
of the possibility
that we could have dystopian outcomes
[Music]
it depends it depends on um whether
artificial intelligence turns out to be
the best way
to develop enhancements and i i mean in
particular
i think artificial intelligence
technology will inevitably help with
medical developments
um but what i mean in particular is you
might wonder if everybody will
utilize brain chips to augment their
intelligence
um it depends if that's the most
efficient and
medically safest way for us to augment
our intelligence there could be
other kinds of enhancements um you know
so
it really depends on how the medicine
moves forward
for example you could use just
nanotechnology
and regular biology to try to enhance
intelligence
i do suspect that as society moves
forward
people will want and be able to enhance
both their cognitive and perceptual
abilities
[Music]
consciousness is the felt quality of
experience
so when you see the rich use of a sunset
or when you stub your toe
when you smell the aroma of your
espresso shot
it feels like something to be you um
from the inside
you are the subject of experience and
you don't really know
directly what it's like to be anybody
else they can tell you and you can
observe their behaviors
but you realize that they're conscious
but anyway consciousness is essentially
private
and it's really the most personal aspect
of our life because every feeling we
have is through the lens of our
conscious experience
why do we need to be conscious why does
it even feel like
anything from the inside to be us um
cognitive science tells us
that the brain engages in information
processing that it's
um basically a computational engine so
why do we need to be conscious if it's
all just information processing
why does it need to have a felt quality
of experience that's the hard problem
of consciousness and that's due to the
philosopher david chalmers
i don't like the dichotomy human
and ai because i think in the future
we will be increasingly integrated with
artificial intelligence
but what i'm not clear on is whether the
integration will happen through
primarily the use of wearables
facebook already has a wristband which
detects motion initiation in the brain
and it's going into beta testing in only
a few
months or if it would be through
something like neural link technology
brain chip technology and it may be that
first we see wearables and later it
evolves into
you know ai actually inside of the head
um so i do think that us versus them
is not subtle enough it's going to be a
matter of integration
all right um but i don't think
that as we move into the future we could
fully merge with artificial intelligence
either
i don't think an unenhanced human
unfortunately could transition over
and become a form of artificial
intelligence in fact i'll be talking
about that i'm sure
in the panel later today with uh
some transhumanist because the
transhumanists do believe
that we could actually merge with ai so
for example people like elon musk
and the late stephen hawking believe
that you could replace
parts of your brain with microchips and
actually survive
the death of the brain
[Music]
well it depends on the domain of ai
research and ai applications that we're
talking about so
when it comes to social media are we
being sensible
no i mean look at the media bubbles
or excuse me the algorithmic bubbles
that amplified social discontent
on facebook or think about the click
bait that we see
in the media and it's not the fault of
the reporters it's the system
you know you're forced to basically
write very quick articles
in only a few hours and then they become
clickbait
um you know so i mean in that domain
i'm very unhappy but in other domains um
why
you know artificial intelligence isn't
necessarily problematic i mean
wow if it's helping compute difficult
algorithms that humans can't really
compute efficiently
then what's wrong with that um it's
transformative
um in you know lots of different domains
even looking for
um disease cures like you know ai is
looking for
um potential vaccines and therapies for
covin
as we speak for more debates talks and
interviews
subscribe today to the institute of art
and ideas
at iai tv
you